all right this is one of those nights
where you stop everything you're doing
even as you are lounging on your patio
with little don julio on ice thank you
chris sims for introducing me to that
to do a video
about cam newton the top 10 quarterback
as identified by chris sims in the list
we just counted down last week
to the patriots yes the patriots a
one-year deal pft has confirmed
incentive laden and a situation where
the patriots took the leap of faith in
reliance upon representations from cam
newton's agents that he's healthy
because they understand how determined
he is to prove himself and now the
former auburn quarterback will be
competing with another former auburn
quarterback jared stidham second year
fourth round pick
cam newton number one overall pick from
2011 and if healthy one of the best
quarterbacks in the nfl and oh by the
way if you're playing pft bingo at home
center square cam newton has a 2-0
all-time record against the new england
patriots yes i've said that before yes
i'll say it again and yes i'm saying it
right now cam newton all-time 2-0
against the patriots and one of the
reasons that he and other mobile
quarterbacks do well against the
patriots because the patriots scheme
based upon the play that's called the
talent of the patriots defense often
doesn't allow them to pivot when the
play that's called breaks down to
backyard football which is what a mobile
athletic quarterback is very good at
effecting and that is what cam newton
can do if that play that's called breaks
down again 2-0 all-time against the
patriots now a chance to win games with
the patriots first up he's got to win
the job but with the deal being done
more than a month before camp opens
he'll have ample opportunity to learn
the offense get ready to go and prove
that he's better option for bill
belichick post tom brady
than jared stidham would be it will make
a 2020 season even more intriguing
hopefully we will have one and check
back monday for plenty more on this move
and other things happening in the nfl we
don't have pft live but we will be doing
some videos from right here tomorrow and
for the next three weeks but we're on
our summer hiatus but the nfl never
stops cam newton to the patriots go back
to enjoying your sunday night because
i sure will
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports